letzten samstag flughafen amsterdam
teile l 598 landet aus kapstadt kommend
in den niederlanden
tripolis tor zur welt und einfallstor
für omicron den cupid 19 erreger in der
neuesten weltweit gefürchteten variante
das flugzeug stoppt es spricht der
kapitän
auf einen chat war eine urlauberin nach
diese bilder wartet sechs stunden im
flugzeug dem terminal in nachbarschaft
mit der neuen variante
es ist jetzt fünf uhr alle sollten ihren
test haben aber da ist noch eine lange
schlange die leute wurden zunehmend
sauer
wir treffen paula zimmermann zwei tage
später in der nähe von utrecht mit dem
abstand den im terminal nicht alle
einheiten
als das testen begann kam alle auf einem
haufen zusammen sie dachten wer als
erster mit dem test dran ist darf als
erster raus einer vom gesundheitsamt
schrie
abstand halten und da wurde echt böse es
war schon ein bisschen chaotisch wie
kraus andere flüge aus südafrika seien
nicht zu streng kontrolliert worden und
heute wird bekannt dass iris zirkuliert
schon länger im land die behörden pannen
mit omikron für viele niederländer ein
weiterer beleg der kleine staat der
großes leistet das war einmal es ist zum
genau
wir sind in haarlem bei amsterdam sieben
tage inzidenz
880 in die niederlanden ist das
durchschnitt soziologieprofessorin
jacqueline van stäglin wird sitzt dem
homeoffice schon wieder
das gefühl der bürger ist heute sagt die
regierung dies eine woche später sagt
sie dass dadurch erhöht sich die
unsicherheit in dieser krise
ich höre die leute in den nachrichten
wie sie sagen wir brauchen jetzt einen
starken politischen führer der herbe
berufe anstellt
doch dauer premier mark rutte ist nur
geschäftsführer er sucht seit märz nach
mehrheiten lässt etwa kinos und theater
öffnen nur um sie wochen später wieder
zu schließen fährt also zickzack durch
die pandemie bis letzten freitag das
scheint auf diese zahlen sind hoch höher
am höchsten diesmal ist es mit ein paar
kleinen verschärfung nicht getan
sagt und ordnet doch nur locker und
leicht an um 17 uhr schließt was nicht
täglicher bedarf ist auch das box sozial
ein café mit 15 mitarbeitern
australischen chef und ironische
untertitel
ich hätte die dinge lieber schwarz oder
weiß in diesem land machen sie alles
grau sie wollen allen gerecht werden
aber es wäre besser wir machen ein
halbes jahr zu unterhalten hilfen
zimmermann darf ohnehin nicht ins café
wartet auf den zweiten test hadert mit
der heimat bei coffee und sirup
doch in den niederlanden hat die politik
diese bildungs kultur und das wissen wir
bürger wir sind nicht so gut im befolgen
von regeln und anordnungen
rosen oder ständig eine kleine eine
sichtbare minderheit kennt keine regeln
vor zwölf tagen in rotterdam randale die
das land so noch nie sah ein
feuerwehrmann bank um sein leben
wir mussten weg und sein auto einfach
brennen dass das feuer hätte aus haus
daneben überspringen können da waren
leute dass sich fürchten muss dass sie
mit steinen werfen dass die polizei mit
scharfer waffen schießt das habe ich
noch nie erlebt und will es auch nicht
noch mal erleben
heute macht die zahl der demos heute
sechsmal höher als 2013 doch die gewalt
nehme zu sagt die soziologin
die randale gibt es nicht und das heißt
auch die randalierer gibt es auch nicht
die meisten seien junge männer darunter
viele
daneben gibt es die die wirklich zur
demo gehen um zu protestieren
von den steifen sich dann einige ab in
dem moment in dem die stimmung umschlägt
gehen die meisten nach hause ein kleiner
teil bleibt und die können dann mit
gezogen werden und krawall machen
die polarisierung im land habe aber
schon früher begonnen mal sind es
viehzüchter die die regierung zum
umweltschutz zwingt mal familien die sie
pauschal unter dem verdacht des
sozialbetrugs stellt immer ging
vertrauen zu bruch
sie sehen also in der letzten zeit wurde
die kluft zwischen bürger und staat
immer größer auf
zurück zu paula zimmermann dem fluggast
aus kapstadt es ist mittwochmorgen der
zweite test steht an ihr laufe die nase
sagt sie ihr mann habe kopfschmerzen
eben im auto sagt er wenn ich mich nach
zwei jahren nun doch noch angesteckt
habe dann war es am samstag ins ripol da
waren so viele positiv naja wir werden
sehen
ihr testergebnis erwartet sie heute
nacht sie hat noch hoffnung dass diese
erste begegnung mit unikum glimpflich
ausgeht für sie und für die niederlande